the one point that i really want
to hammer home and sims and i talked
about it a little bit today without the
benefit of some words of wisdom from
brett favre hall of fame quarterback who
played most of his career but
for a season and a half at most
before the nfl had its concussion
epiphany and he played 321 straight
games
that guy clearly had concussions he
clearly returned
to games in which he had suffered a
concussion there was no
protocol requiring that someone who was
diagnosed with a concussion be held out
of action and andy reid the chiefs coach
himself mentioned that
in the old days patrick mahomes on
sunday once he was in the concussion
protocol
in those old days would have been back
in the game at some point
before the game ended that's just the
way it was and farv's
comments to tmz for monday i think very
important for everyone to take to heart
now look we
all as football fans just want to be
entertained you know unless you're a
bills fan
you're hoping that patrick mahomes gets
cleared to play after suffering that
concussion on sunday and i've seen
different reports and different accounts
of whether or not it was a neck
thing and his neck was impinged in some
way and that caused the wooziness and he
didn't really have a concussion look
he was diagnosed with a concussion
period he's in the concussion protocol
period and he's not getting out until
team doctors and most importantly the
independent neurologist say so
far's advice to mahomes is don't try to
fudge things don't
keep your mouth shut if you have a
headache on friday or saturday we've
seen cases where
quarterbacks have put their hands in the
air and said hey i'm
feeling the effects of a concussion when
no one else would have known
the difference if you feel that way you
owe it to yourself and you owe it to the
sport to say so and
the reality is no competitor is going to
be inclined to do that that would be the
ultimate act of true selflessness not
for your team
but for the sport for yourself it's one
of those weird
situations where it's important for you
to be
selfish your short-term selfish nature
is i want to play your long-term selfish
nature
is i'm not going to play under these
circumstances
and that's the kind of selfish that the
sport is trying
to to promote from a cultural standpoint
it isn't there yet but that's what the
goal is that's what the hope is and
you know i get uncomfortable when i see
the report that
was published earlier today from espn i
think it was an adam schafter report
that the chiefs are optimistic he'll be
cleared to play
i don't want any pressure i don't want
any expectation
i want the protocol to play itself out
and there will be pressure
on the independent neurologist because
this is important to the league
to have patrick holmes on the field this
weekend and i've been
pressing gently for some transparency
and some information about
who's making the final call how is that
going to work they'll give you the
protocol
but they're not going to give you names
and i understand they don't want
individuals to be pressured by anyone
but at some point
someone's got to sign the paper that
says
cleared or not cleared and i
i i think it's it's fair at some point
to ask who that is
and who's making this decision and
it's it's it's a far more important
point than we realize because it doesn't
happen very often
i can't think of a time that there was a
question about a quarterback
one of the best quarterbacks in the nfl
with a concussion whether or not he was
going to get cleared before the next
game a game of this magnitude
that to me unless i'm forgetting
something which is entirely possible
over the course of the last 12 years
this feels new and if it's not brand new
it's something that hasn't happened in a
long time so we'll be keeping an eye on
that throughout the course of the week
without further ado
let's bring in miles simmons the latest
addition to profootballtalk.com
previously covered
the panthers and the rams and miles
joins us now good afternoon miles how
are you
doing well mike how are you i'm doing
great it's great to have you let's start
where i was just uh talking about
patrick mahomes and this concussion
thing isn't it i mean
am i missing something is there a time
where we've had an issue like this with
a
such a great quarterback with such an
impactful game and we're caught in this
situation where we just have to wait and
see what the doctors do
yeah i i don't recall one and you know
as you were just saying that i was
trying to think of one and i really
couldn't but i think you're right it is
so consequential what this is going to
be
for patrick mahomes because as you said
this is important for the league
that he plays in this game and so you
don't want that
whoever that independent neurologist is
to feel any pressure
to clear patrick mahomes if he is not
ready to play and i think
you know based on what brett favre was
saying it's not just about
uh being important for the league it's
about being important for him
and his family now his fiancee is
pregnant
now this is something that i think has
to go through your mind at some point
who am i going to be for my child in the
future who am i going to be for my
family and so
if mahomes is feeling any effects of
anything he should not be out there
yeah and that's where far's advice is
coming from because
farv played in that era where there
wasn't the sensitivity that there now
is so he's walking around like so many
former players who played in that era
miles
thinking that there's a ticking time
bomb in their brains and imagine waking
up with that every day thinking is today
the day i'm going to start to lose my
faculties that's where his advice is for
patrick mahomes and it's hard
when you're 24 25 years old to envision
a future when you're 54 55 but trust me
guys
if you're lucky it will happen that's
where brett favre is coming from and i
think that's where patrick mahomes
really needs to take his advice to heart
yeah absolutely and uh it's you know
with somebody who's still in their 20s
it's
a little hard for me to envision that
kind of thing you know what
coming up at some point in my life and
hopefully it does but i think you're
absolutely right mike
you cannot just be in the moment
sometimes when it comes to your brain
this is something that you need to have
for the rest of your life if you're
going to have
a good life and you know and keep all of
your mental faculties and
obviously we also want to see patrick
mahomes play this game
for as long as possible so if that has
anything to do with it like i said
before you know if he's feeling anything
he needs to not play
and we're in the information business so
we crave more information not less and
i'd love to know who's making this
decision but at the same time
i don't want someone having pressure
placed upon them by
over-the-top chiefs fans who insist on
their quarterback being available like i
i don't want anyone to have to go into
hiding this week but
this is this is the job this is the way
it works
and there's only so much that you can
keep tucked behind the curtain before
people start wondering what's going on
and you know what brett favre said
during that interview with tmz is
this is a test for the nfl and let's see
if they get it right and there won't be
a right or wrong
we won't know because it's not like
miles they're going to put patron homes
on the field
and people are going to be saying wow
he's messed up still a week later i mean
it's not going to be perceptible from
the viewers
standpoint if there is some lingering
fogginess or headaches or anything like
that
we're not going to notice it and that's
why
it's even more important to fully
understand where the boxes get checked
who's
checking the boxes who's making sure
that the long-term health and safety of
patrick mahomes is being protected
yeah exactly and so if if people
i think were to find out who that
neurologist is like you said there could
be some meddlesome chiefs fans
i probably know a couple who are very
interested in seeing whether or not
patrick mahomes
is going to be able to play but at the
same time
it is one of these things where it is
it's bigger
than just this game and as we know this
is a huge game but
it's it's more about his career how can
his career continue to unfold
and how can he be a good example for
guys to maybe
say look if something's not right you
know you need to say
something you cannot just continue to go
out there and play
and risk yourself and your long-term
health just for one game it's just not
worth it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports